thank you so much for coming and today
the theme of our workshop is a proof
complexity toolbox
and um we have
three speakers who will tell us on all
the different
cool techniques that you could use to
prove beautiful results
in proof complexity beautiful results
about
solvers and stuff well mainly proof
complexity today
and um our fourth speaker
is jana achremia
we're very happy to have joanna here she
uh have worked with alberta serious and
other people
so if you've heard some recent talks by
them you probably
got a glimpse of their work and um
she's now working at university of
bordeaux
and her work brings together two
beautiful
areas of logic proof complexity
uh and finite model theory together with
algorithm and constraint satisfaction
so please jana the floor is yours
thank you so hello uh everybody
and uh thank you very much uh the
organizers for
inviting me to uh to talk at this
workshop
so uh yeah so antonina asked me to
talk about connections between proof
complexity and finite model theory so
that's what i'm gonna do today so uh
well i don't really have uh much time to
get
into details of and give you an
introduction to finance model theory so
let me just say that
in general finite model theory is the
study of expressive power of logics
on the class of finite structures
so what i want to uh talk about today is
that there are surprisingly tight
connections between finite model theory
and
proof complexity uh and
some uh some of those connections
provide tools for proving lower bounds
uh
improve complexity and actually this
this
this those connections seem to be not
very well explored so
they seem to be a lot of interesting
open questions which also i would like
to
advertise uh in this talk so the plan is
the following
i'm going to start with a few basic
definitions
one thing that i'm not going to define
so in this talk i will
mention several logics
so i'm not going to define any of them
and at the end of the talk uh if
somebody wants to
see a definition then then i will show a
definition but since i'm not going to be
getting into
any details of of proofs of things that
are expressed expressed in those logics
i kind of
don't see the point of giving the
precise definitions but
the i mean the important thing to know
that all those logics
are well studied in finite model theory
there are
known upper and lower bounds and unknown
techniques for proving upper and lower
bounds
okay so i will start anyway with a few
basic definitions
then i want to talk about uh
work on uh resolution of of resolution
with and resolution space
so those those results i think are
rather well known in the proof
complexity
uh community so i'm gonna but anyway i'm
gonna briefly mention
those those beautiful results from a
while back
and then i want to focus on more recent
work
uh on on the on the intersection of
proof complexity and find that model
theory on results which i think that are
less known and that provides interesting
tools for
for proving lower bounds
and of course if you have any questions
please interrupt and
and ask okay so
as i said we will start with uh just a
few basic definitions so
i will be talking a lot about structures
so by structures all structures will
define it
uh by a structure i mean a finite
relational structure so we have
uh we have uh so
okay so we have an uh a universe so a
finite set
a and we have a bunch of relations so
each relation
is just a set of tuples of
some arity so set of set of tuples of
the
the elements of the universe of certain
arity and
another uh basic important
notion is the notion of a homomorphism
so
if i have two relational structures with
corresponding relations so here uh the
relation r1
in the relational structure a is of the
same is in particular of the same rit as
the relation r1
in the relational structure b then a
homomorphism is just a function
from the universe of a to the universe
of b
such that every tuple so for every
relation
every couple in this relation in the
structure a is mapped into a tuple
in the relation in the in the
corresponding relation in the structure
b
so uh i hope this is clear so just uh
an example which will also be important
later on in my talk so
for instance uh three satisfiability
can be seen as a homomorphing problem so
as a question whether there exists a
homomorphism between two structures
so i will illustrate this by an example
so here we have a three c and f so
what does it's what i mean what does it
say this this i mean
if we want to satisfy it what does it
mean well we want
this tuple of variables so x1 x2 and x3
we want it to be mapped to some tuple
which satisfies this clause so
anything except for 0 0 0 and
and so on so we can we can
formal for formalize this as a
homomorphism problem
in the first structure so this is the
structure which is built
from the from this 3cnf
we have the universe which contains the
elements of the structure
and we have relations that corresponds
to every type of clause that we can use
so we have a relation that corresponds
to the clause where there are no
negation
when there are no negations and indeed
in our three c and f we have three
clauses
with no negations and then we have i
mean
we have two to the third relations so in
particular
we also have a relation which
corresponds to the clause where the
first
literal is negated and then we have two
literals without negations
and in this relation we have this tuple
and then the second the second um
relational structure actually does not
depend on the
on the three c and f it's it's it just
depends on the number three so the
number of uh
of literals in each clause so this is
the structure which
i mean we want to find uh satisfying
assignments so we have
two elements in the structure zero and
one true and false
and the relations in the structure b
encode the satisfying assignments
so in the relation in the first relation
we have old tuples between
except for zero zero zero and etc etc so
indeed
if we want to so so indeed like
satisfying this uh this
three cnf is exactly the same as finding
a homomorphism from
this structure to this structure because
what does it mean
to find a homomorphism well this will be
a mapping from those
variables to truth values such that
this tuple has to be mapped to something
in this relation
this tuple has to be mapped to something
in this relation so
exactly the same thing as we have we
as we have said in a different language
in this formula
so i hope this is uh this is clear so
this will be
uh yeah this will be like this kind of
encoding will be will be important
uh later on uh in the talk
so those are the the two basic
definitions
that i wanted to uh uh to introduce at
the beginning
and now let me talk about the first uh
well first results that i want to
mention
so um those are two theorems from
a work of actuarias and dalmo from i
think this is i mean this is the journal
version of the conference version
appeared a few years before so what they
showed is that if we have a
an rcnf then uh
this rc rc and f then it has a
resolution refutation of
width k if and only if spoiler wins the
existential
k plus one pebble game on those two
structures that i discussed before
so this is here we are talking about
rcnfs so this is why
here i have uh the structure like i mean
this is br so this is this similar
construction just for
uh for uh clauses with with more
literals so if we would put uh here
three c and f
those two structures would be exactly
the structures that i constructed on the
previous slide
so of course i'm gonna define in a
second what is an existential capable
capable game and in what context it's uh
it appears in finite model theory
so let me just say that uh this result
uh
allowed to rederive or all previously
known
uh with lower bounds resolution with
lower bounds
and also allowed to prove uh the
following uh beautiful
theorem uh which says that the
resolution space is
lower bounded by resolution with
uh yeah so so those are the first
theorem that i want to mention so now
let me discuss them in more detail so
for instance so the first thing is
what is the existential capable pebble
game
so in the existential capable game we
have
two players spoiler and duplicator and
they are playing on two relational
structures so here we have uh
two relate example of two relational
structures which are just under
under undirected graphs and let's say
that let's fix k to b2
so k is the number of pebbles so spoiler
and duplicator have corresponding pairs
of pebbles here we have two pairs of
pebbles
and they place them on the elements of
the structure so
let us see how it looks like so spoiler
can pick
the red pebble and place it on the soap
spoiler always plays
places the the pebbles on the left
of the on the left side structure and
duplicator answers by
picking up the corresponding pebble and
placing it
on the element of the right hand side
structure and what we have to
maintain is that the mapping that we
have defined here so
here the mapping is just this element is
mapped to the to this element
that this map this mapping has to be a
partial homomorphism so for now there is
i mean there's nothing to check uh i
mean of course this mapping is a partial
homomorphism
so now the spoiler picks up another
pebble places is here places this here
let's say
and then duplicate our answers by
picking the corresponding pebble
placing it here so now indeed we have a
this this mapping
that those pebbles define is a partial
homomorphism
because here we have so here we have an
edge
and here this and this edge is mapped to
this edge
so now uh the game continues spoiler can
pick up
this pebble and let's say put it here
and the duplicator actually does not
have to do anything because
the mapping i mean doesn't have to pick
up the blue pebble and move it anywhere
because the mapping is
is still a homomorphism actually this
example is trivial because
this whole i mean this whole structures
structure maps homomorphically into this
structure so of course
duplicator can play forever
so yeah so the goal of duplicator is to
maintain this homomorphism forever and
we say that
duplicator wins the game if he can do it
and spoiler wins the game if he manages
to
force duplicator to not be able to
maintain the partial homomorphism
those games were introduced in the
context of
finite model theory by colitis and vardi
in the 90s
so they were this was in the context of
characterizing the power of
uh data log so in other words the
existential positive fragment of least
fixed point logic
for constant satisfaction problems so i
mean uh
yeah like this is this is uh this is uh
one way of uh i mean
this is what this this pebble game
characterizes we say
like what they showed is that duplicator
has a winning strategy in the
existential capable game
if and only if every sentence of the
existential positive favorable
variable fragment of least fixed point
logic satisfied
in the left hand side structure is also
satisfied in the right hand side
structure
so i mean this is not very important for
our
our goal now but i just wanted to to
kind of introduce the context in which
those pebble games were first introduced
there is a question in the chat uh do
you want to read it or do you want to
read it i think i cannot read it i mean
since i'm sure on the screen i don't
see how i know uh johnny hanson's asking
how does d respond when s put the pebble
on the lower corner in the example
uh again let's go to the okay so yes
if if spoiler puts up okay sure so if
spoiler puts the pebble
uh here this is the
this is the question yes okay
yes so so since there is no edge
here there is no edge so you don't uh
since
since we only need to maintain a
homomorphism
no no edges can be mapped to edges
that's not not a problem
so actually duplicator can just not do
anything because
since here we have an edge then whatever
spoiler i mean okay
as long as spoiler does not put two
pebbles in one
place then duplicator has to do the same
but otherwise
spoiler can move the pebble around here
and duplicator doesn't have to do
anything
because both edges and non-edges can be
mapped to edges
that's not a problem
okay okay so if this answers the
question then let's move
forward okay so uh
so now in the context of so
i mean this this result uh is uh i think
quite well
well known in in the proof complexity
community and it was quite influential
so i think in the context so i mean as
as far as i know in the in the proof
complexity
uh community rather what
what people are talking about is uh so
okay so here we can we can start with a
duplicator strategy
so a strategy of duplicator it's uh kind
of easy to see is a
locally consistent family of partial
homomorphisms
so if a duplicator can make can maintain
a homomorphism this means that there
exists such a so i will not get into
details locally consistent family of
homomorphism of
so in this case this will be size two
and
if we want to forget about the
structures and just think about
the the cnf then we can think about this
as simply a locally consistent family of
non-falsifying partial truth assignments
where the where the number of pebbles is
just the the number of variables to
which we assign truth values
so i think this is the the perspective
which is more often taken uh in the
proof complexity results
and i just would like to mention a very
recent result which uh
uses uh uses this result and and kind of
similar perspective
uh
with and space measures so there is a
theorem of
galactic origin and tapen from 2019
where they relate
space for polynomial calculus to width
of resolution so uh yeah that's just to
to to to show that uh i mean uh those uh
though actually
those techniques that were introduced by
by albert end and
uh victor dalmow
yeah are are being used
so uh yeah so that was just uh i mean uh
since that's
that's kind of known uh i just wanted to
to mention it because i
also find it very nice so now i would
like to move
to things that i think are much less
known
so and to kind of make a bridge between
those results and what i want to talk
about next
so this is uh just a reminder of the of
the
colitis and verti theorem where the
where the pebble games appeared
so actually in his earlier work uh
albert showed that
uh in some sense uh resolution with can
be characterized
by uh sentences of existential positive
fragment
of least fixed point logic so i mean
this is what he showed so he showed that
there exists a sentence of existential
positive
2k variable fragment of least fixed
point logic
such that for every 3 c and f
if the width uh i mean if the resolution
width
is at least k then this this structure
that
that we define satisfies this sentence
and on the other hand if the structure
that we talked about
uh satisfies the sentence then the width
is at most 2k
so this is not a precise
characterization but uh
well somehow uh quite precise i would
say
uh so now moving to a much
more recent work uh i wanted just to
mention uh so i'm not gonna get into the
details here
but i think this is a very beautiful
paper uh well quite recent paper
a finite model theoretic view on
propositional proof complexity by grad
delgroy pago and pakusa
from 2019 so they establish
i would say similar but most more
precise correspondence between
several proof systems and logics
uh studied in in finite model theory
so for instance they show that uh in
some sense so this is why i don't want
to really get
into the details here because i think
that explaining the the actual sense
uh i mean the the details here would be
would be
uh would be time consuming and perhaps
not
so useful but i mean the idea is that
what they show is that for instance
the resolution of with k is exactly
corresponds to the
existential fragment of fixed point
logic and similarly
uh polynomial calculus of degree k
corresponds uh
in some sense that they make precise uh
to fix point logic with counting
so i mean those are uh those are very
nice results but i think that
there is one aspect of those results
which can be
particularly useful for proving lower
bounds
for proof complexity so
in particular what they show is i could
say
stated informally that existence of
proofs of certain complexity
is expressible in logic of course i mean
proofs in some proof systems that they
study
and expressible in logic is i mean
different logics for for different group
systems
so here there's an example of such a
theorem so this is a
theorem from the same paper so what they
show is that for every k
there exists an an fpc formula so fixed
point logic with counting formula with
of k variables such that for any system
p of polynomials p has a degree
k refutation in polynomial calculus
if and only if well this system
satisfies the sentence
so by by this i mean that of course we
i mean we cannot really say that the
system of polynomials satisfies some
logical formula so what we need to do is
we need to fix some encoding
of a system of polynomials as a
relational structure so this can be done
this can be done in several ways several
natural ways
i'm not going to get into the details so
okay so what it means is that
if we fix the complexity of proofs like
in this case
degree if we bound the degree then there
exists a formula
which also uses bounded resources so
this
bounded number of variables means i mean
the the number of variables in the logic
can be seen as a as a sort of
resource so this means that if we have
and in this case we do have lower bounds
for the number of variables
for this logic which they are talking
about here
then we can use such a theorem to prove
lower bounds
for uh polynomial calculus in this in
this concrete example
so i'm not gonna use this theorem to
prove lower bounds but i would like to
talk about one more thing and
and and show how uh this i mean a
similar theorem for
uh sum of squares proof system and i
would like to show how
this theorem i mean this this uh
that the fact that existence of sum of
squares proof can be expressible in
certain logic can be used can be indeed
used to to shoulder or bounds improve
complexity
so um what i wanted to discuss but i
don't know if i really have time but
well maybe let's
let's try so the last thing that i
wanted to discuss is a theorem that
we showed with albert in 2018
and so this and and also as a
as a kind of side result i wanted to
also show
one lower bound which can be used which
can be used using which can be
proved using uh results from finite
model theory
so uh the the thing that we showed is
that for the graph isomorphism problem
uh
the literally adam's polymer calculus
and sum of squares per systems
are equally powerful up to a constant
factor loss in the degree
so we are talking about the graph
isomorphism problem so uh well
graphs are isomorphic so here we have
two graphs
there are the what i mean by an
isomorphism is just a bijection between
those the vertices of those graphs such
that this this bijection preserves
both edges and no edges so in this case
i mean yeah it's it's more than a
homomorphism if we don't have an edge
on the left-hand side then we cannot
have an edge on the right-hand side
so um okay so so this uh the
graphisomorphism problem can be easily
encoded
as a system of polynomial equations
so i think this this is i mean this is
really easy so perhaps they can just
keep it so
here we have a system of polynomial
equations and it's very easy to see that
this system has a solution if and only
if the graphs
are has a has a zero one solution if and
only if the graphs are
uh isomorphic so we can talk about
uh uh proof systems for
for systems of polynomial inequalities
so i don't think that
sum of squares and charlie adams were
defined so
let me just briefly define them so if we
have a system of polynomial
inequalities like here and of course an
equation can be
uh can be encoded as a pair of
inequalities then a sum of square
refutation
is a polynomial identity of this form
where
the pjs can be either the original
polynomials that appear here or
one of the boolean axioms so those those
one of those those things where where
the x
i is one of the variables that appear in
the original polynomials
and the shelly adams reputation is a
similar thing just
instead of sum of squares here we have
things that are called
extended monomials so
uh i mean basic things about sum of
squares and shelly adams uh
if the system of polynomial inequalities
has no zero in solution then we can
always refute it
in both systems but the degree of
refutation
can be linear in the number of variables
and also
sum of squares is stronger than surely
adams
so yeah so what we show uh with albert
is that uh as i said that uh basically
sum of squares in the end is the same as
uh as
uh shall i adams is in the end uh almost
the same as sum of squares for the graph
isomorphism problem
so there are several things that have
already been known which
which showed that actually also
polynomial calculus of
of degree d is uh is in between
so it's equally powerful but maybe i
will not
get into the details of this whole cycle
of indications so let me just uh
talk about the the theorem which
actually is a key
uh to to prove this collapse
so what we show and this is this is an
analog of this
theorem that i that i showed you for for
polynomial calculus
uh for every k there exists a
formula so this is uh infinitary
counting logic
with o of k variables such that if we
have a system of polynomial inequalities
then it
it has a uh k degree k
sum of square refutation if and only if
it satisfies
uh this formula so in particular we have
we have uh also a formula that uh
i mean it's it's easy to derive from
this that uh
if this system has a degree k sos
reputation then we also have the formula
psi which uh which is
satisfied by i mean this system has
degree k
sos refutation if and only if the
disjoint union of the two graphs
satisfies
some formula psi which can be easily
constructed from this
phi uh so just one important thing about
this result so this
is uh heavily building on previous work
uh by
anderson davar and holm and davaren wang
so i'm not gonna
get into the details of the proof of
this theorem but uh
i mean uh it's uh it's it's building on
on the
on the fact that uh the ellipsoid method
is expressible in first
uh in fixed point logic with counting
which is uh due to
those authors okay so once we have this
uh the result is uh it's kind of
easy to show so if we have uh if the the
system of
uh of polynomial equations has a degree
d
sum of square refutation then we have
this formula psi
which which characterizes uh the
existence of degree d
sos refutations so in particular the
the joint union of g and h satisfies the
formula
psi so the formula psi has c times the
variables where c
is an independent constant and of course
the
sum the the disjoint union of g
and the g does not satisfy phi
sorry because of course i mean those
graphs are isomorphic so definitely we
cannot prove in
in sum of squares that they are not
isomorphic
so well this this means that i mean this
this
sentence psi certifies the fact that
there exists a sentence which
distinguishes which
satisfied by those guys and not
satisfied
by by by this structure which means that
there is also a sentence of the same
number of variables which is satisfied
here and not satisfied here
and then we can use a characterization
of uh ad series and maneeva
who showed that this is this holds
exactly when this system has a degree d
has a degree cd some shirley adams
reputation
so cd is exactly the same cd which uh
which
which is here which uh i mean uh i'm
going a bit fast but
which which proves what we wanted to
prove so
the existence of degree d sum of square
refutation
implies the existence of degree c d
shelley adams refutation
so that's that's the end of the proof of
this theorem and
as i promised uh so i think i should be
finishing
but as i promised uh this uh this uh
theorem so let's let us just go back to
it for a second
so as i promised this theorem which
which talks about the expressive
expressibility of existing
of the of the proof existence for stem
of squares
in in some concrete logic can be used
also to
uh derive in a kind of immediate way
lower bounds for proof complexity
so uh there was a famous theorem of uh
cyphura immermann from the 90s
so they showed that there is a family of
pairs of non-isomorphic graphs
with oauth and vertices such that
those graphs are not distinguishable by
formulas of uh this infinitary counting
logic so this this logic that i was
talking about in this context
with n variables so an immediate
cholerae of
this of this theorem is uh that uh
for refuting i mean well of course for
non-isomorphic graph if we want to
refute
this system of polynomial equations in
sum of squares
then this would in general require uh
degree uh linear in the number of
variables
uh so this was this theorem was proved
by uh
o'donnell and and co-authors uh in 2014
so actually they uh i mean if we if we
see this
uh i mean once we have this theorem
about uh which which uh
relates sum of squares with uh with
infinitary counting logic
then this is immediate their proof is uh
i mean
it's a long proof so what they what they
show is they they actually construct uh
absolute expectation to
show that uh i mean uh
less like you cannot have reputations of
of small degree
uh so this is not at all how they do
this and
using this uh this result which uh which
is kind of uh
which connects proof complexity to
finite model theory
this uh this is just an immediate
consequence
uh yeah so that's it uh i think that's
anyway i i
run over time so uh thank you very much
i think that my main message is that
uh i mean there are there are uh
interesting connections
and especially this this question about
whether
the existence of proofs for for
different proof systems can be expressed
in
in certain well-studied logics is a very
interesting one
there are tools for proving such results
so there are existing results of this of
this form so there are tools for proving
such results
and they they they are promising in the
sense that
i mean they they might have interesting
consequences for for proof complexity
thank you thank you so much this this is
really
really beautiful but i think it was
going very fast but
just to make friends um this is very
fast and unfortunately those workshop
talks are just
a glimpse into this whole beautiful
world
but uh if people are interested
that nothing stops you from talking to
the speakers and saying hey let's start
the reading group on it
can you give a longer talk at the
mutually convenient time wherever you
are in the world so
please do it if you're interested this
is beautiful okay
so questions comments
you could say it you could type in in
the chat if you're not indeed you could
raise your hand
i have a question antonina
so this is a small philosophical
question
you know there was this uh again a
interplay
a connection established many years ago
between
a complexity theory and fundamental
theory and they speak known as
descriptive complexity
and part of the hope there that will be
able to prove separation result in
complex theory
from the logic side and that
the beautiful dream did not quite pan
out because it turns out that it's
actually
uh generally easier to prove separations
and complexity reason in the logic side
so we're able to go in other direction
so now we have this beautiful connection
between proof complexity and final model
theory where is it easier to prove
separation results
is there or maybe it's not easier in one
of the others
where does the lower bounds flow from
which direction lower bounds flow
so i mean i would say that at least
so far i have the feeling that uh the
connection with finite model theory is
established too late
to be able to prove new lower bounds
which is somehow unfortunate
so i kind of feel that if we were able
to establish
this those connections before then we
could uh i mean actually the lower
bounty logic precedes the lower bounds
improve complexity but the connection
kind of was not there so they had to be
in some sense
rediscovered i mean this is an example
this is this example of
of the lower bound for for the graphic
isomorphism problem
and sum of square proof systems system
it's it was proved before before
in in proof of complexity but of course
the tools in finite model theory
existed much much earlier it's just that
there was no connection between
the logic and the proof system
can we go back for example using this
this powerful tool of games
and show that it gives us a simpler
simpler proofs in improv complexity
low bounce i think that would be also
very interesting
even if it's not a new result yeah i
mean i would i mean
i guess it depends on the perspective
but i mean from i would say that from
my point of view this this proof i mean
this proof of lower bound for
for sum of squares and the graphical
isomorphism problem is
i mean at least for me i would say that
it's easier
uh if you use the the cfi graph then if
you construct by hand the
pseudo expectation uh actually they all
they also use the cfi graphs it's just
that they
they kind of uh yeah do more uh
yeah do they have to do more work since
there is uh
yeah but i think that it is just that it
depends i i would say that probably
depends
on taste okay thank you
okay there are some uh
okay uh there is a question there was a
question the chat
we just got answered
okay uh it was about um
it was a donald trump based on cfi
grafton reduction
parity reasoning
actually i found i found the chat
yes yes
based on cfi graphs
okay more questions comments
just one comment about this thing that
massimo is saying
the o'donnell and others they don't
quite use cfi graphs they use random
systems of linear equations
and then they kind of they build the
pseudo expectation on that
on random systems of linear equations
and then that they convert
to to see the expectation photographs
so that's the reduction they do but they
don't use the gadgets that are using the
games
on in the cfi graphs and those gadgets
in fact are
actually very useful and and that's what
i'm
in my feeling it makes the proof easier
the final model theory proof
in some sense is easier i believe
i think there is another question in the
chat
so that is uh asking can you use the
formulas to search for boundary degree
proofs
i mean as an algorithm
to evaluate the formula on the new
structure
uh i mean uh yeah uh
i mean okay it depends so uh so for
instance if
uh if we are talking about shirley adams
then
uh then you can also have a formula of
this time fixed point logic with
counting which
uh which captures uh bound and degree
charlie adams so in this
in this case you could evaluate the
formula to find
the proof because but i mean this this
formula
that you have just uh i mean this is a
formula which is just a specific way of
running the ellipsoid method so you
wouldn't be doing
anything uh i mean it's it's not it's
not in any way better
than than just uh using the ellipsoid
method for
finding the the boundary degree proof
and then from
for sum of squares this is more
complicated because i mean as we know
there is the problem with
large coefficients so actually the the
logic that we
we used i mean it's it's it's it's a
logic which is not in p
time so you cannot in i mean you cannot
in general use this formula
that exists to to find proofs
i mean well you could but but it's it's
not going to be
an efficient way of of doing it
but in general and also in general like
i mean the the the way we prove
that uh the that that the existence of
proofs in certain proof systems is
expressible in logic
is in like kind of in general but by
taking the
algorithms which which uh
find it was proofs or decide the
existence of those proofs and just
showing that
they can be implemented in a choiceless
way so what logic cannot do is it cannot
just pick an arbitrary element
so those formulas i mean they will not
give you more efficient algorithms
excellent thank you so much and so i
guess i'm the one who does the clapping
for everybody this is absolutely
fascinating thank you